I just like to say that the press has  been attacked before and the press as we  know will be attacked again but I'm  thinking guys that it really is a  testament to how thoroughly and how  thoughtfully we do our jobs well spoken  words by Gayle King last night when she  co-hosted the Alfred I DuPont Columbia  University Awards they honor outstanding  contributions to broadcast journalism  and we're proud to say CBS News foreign  correspondent Elizabeth Palmer received  an award for her reporting on the Syrian  civil war our David Martin accepted an  award for 60 minutes for its look at the  men and women who trained to prepare the  US for the possibility of nuclear war in  our Houston affiliate KHOU received  honors for its investigation into police  body camera program congratulations to  all an impressive group and always nice  when the home town team wins